everyone thinks that Henry Kissinger is
a war criminal and I got really curious
like is he well it turns out that one of
the major reasons why people think he is
is because of the bombing of Cambodia
during the Vietnam war Kissinger oversaw
this illegal and secret carpet bombing
campaign where they dropped an
unfathomable amount of bombs on the
country of Cambodia a country that
wasn't even directly involved in the war
we actually got the data of all of the
bombs that were dropped and when you
display it on a map of Cambodia it's
pretty nuts all of these bombs were
devastating killing approximately
100,000 civilians and displacing more
than 2 million and this is a country
that had a population of 7 million
kinger approved the bombing he approved
the targets he helped keep it secret and
he somehow a few years later got a Nobel
Peace
Prize which apparently he like felt
really bad about it because he knew that
he shouldn't have gotten it and he like
tried to send the trophy back so anyway
this is definitely War crime Vibes um
and it's not the only one that Kissinger
has on his record